[Música]
Hola soy María Clara calle y les doy la
bienvenida a la crónica de medio
ambiente quiero comenzar haciéndoles una
pregunta ven el animal que hay en la
foto a mis espaldas es difícil de notar
porque esta Rana es experta en el
camuflaje ya que su piel se asemeja al
musgo Esta es una de las 380 nuevas
especies que descubrieron en la región
del Gran mecón en el sudeste asiático
también está en la gama o lagarto de
cresta azul de Camboya solo esta especie
cambia de color como mecanismo de
defensa y fue precisamente por ello que
la descubrieron en el mundo solo hay 25
géneros de calotes la familia a la que
pertenece Y ahora descubrieron cuatro
nuevas incluyendo esta calotes getsi
hay reptiles escamosos del género de
geckos y orquídeas nunca antes vistas
Todas están en el gran mecón una
subregión que comprende territorios de
Camboya laos mian mar Tailandia y
Vietnam además hace parte del hotspot de
biodiversidad de Indo birmania o puntos
calientes como se les llama a estos
lugares por Su riqueza de especies por
eso allí encuentran constantemente
nuevas especies desde 1997 han
descubierto casi
3.400 incluyendo las recientes de
acuerdo con el reporte de WWF en 2021
encontraron 175 especies y en 2022 otras
205 la mayoría son nuevas plantas
también hay múltiples reptiles anfibios
y peces el único nuevo mamífero que
encontraron fue un murciélago del tamaño
del pulgar que está en Camboya
a pesar de que esta sigue siendo una
tierra fértil para descubrir la
biodiversidad
WWF advierte que también se evidencia el
riesgo que enfrentan las especies por el
crecimiento de los asentamientos humanos
y los proyectos de desarrollo que hay
cerca de la zona
otros animales que están en peligro
también son los primates en Colombia hay
por lo menos 38 especies de monos de las
cuales 10 son endémicas es decir que
sólo habitan en el territorio nacional
Esto hace de Colombia El tercer país con
mayor diversidad de primates en toda
América Latina por debajo de Brasil y
Perú y el sexto en el mundo Pero al
menos 4 están en peligro de extinción
por eso el documentalista Federico pardo
quiso retratarlas en su proyecto
salvando primates para mostrar su
importancia y las amenazas que enfrentan
veamos la historia
llevar el bosque a la ciudad es la
apuesta de Federico pardo un biólogo
documentalista él se ganó una beca de
National Geographic para construir una
selva multimedia los protagonistas son
las cuatro especies de primates de
Colombia que están en peligro crítico de
extinción el Titi cabeciblanco el mono
araña café el tití del caquetá y el
churuco estos dos últimos son de los
primates más grandes de América más de
40 personas estuvieron 50 días en el
Valle del río Magdalena en el Bosque
Seco Tropical del Caribe y en el pie de
Monte andino amazónico
evidenciaron que la peor amenaza es la
deforestación Hay un problema de
fragmentación dificilísimo del
ecosistema los bosques están partidos
están fragmentados por ganadería por
deforestación Y eso lo que hace es que
las poblaciones estén aisladas
aún así los primates combaten la
deforestación son los jardineros del
Bosque al defecar las semillas de los
frutos que comen un adulto puede disper
sar cerca de 600.000 semillas en un año
una relevancia que Federico quiere
Resaltar
este es lo que llamamos el portal de la
selva o la entrada a la selva y es
literal desconectarnos de la ciudad
entrar por la deforestación que se ve al
principio Y a medida que vamos entrando
a la selva vamos desconectándonos vamos
oyendo diferentes sonidos
hasta que finalmente llegamos a la selva
multimedia que creamos
ocho proyectores con una experiencia de
360 grados para mirar a los primates a
los ojos y sentir la selva en carne
propia Ese es el resultado de trabajar
con biólogos y expertos locales entonces
dentro del equipo había una persona
especialista en escalar y con él
construimos plataformas a 20-30 metros
del piso cerca de los árboles en fruto y
esto nos permite literal estar en la
casa de los primates otro de los
objetivos de salvando primates es apoyar
a organizaciones locales para restaurar
los bosques ha sido un porcentaje de
cada boleta se destina a sembrar un
árbol
la exposición estará disponible en el
Planetario de Bogotá en Colombia
Mientras tanto nosotros hablamos de la
cop 28 Aunque falta un semestre para que
se realice la Cumbre climática de la ONU
en emiratos árabes Unidos ya hay
polémica por la persona que designó el
país anfitrión para presidir las
negociaciones se trata del Sultán al
haber quien es el presidente de la
compañía Estatal de petróleo del país
una de las 21 compañías de combustibles
fósiles que más ha contaminado en los
últimos 30 años según un estudio que
salió en la publicación especializada
One Earth Aunque su nominación se
conoció en enero de este año ahora más
de 130 parlamentarios de Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea escribieron una carta
pidiendo su renuncia la misiva se la
enviaron al presidente Joe biden a la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
Legend al secretario general de la ONU
Antonio Gutiérrez y al secretario
ejecutivo del un F triple c Simon Steel
esto es parte de lo que dice la misiva
los instamos a que aboguen para que
emiratos árabes Unidos retire el
nombramiento del presidente designado de
la cop28 El Sultán al haber jefe de la
compañía Nacional de petróleo de abu
dhabi la decisión de nombrar como
presidente de la cop 28 al director
ejecutivo de una de las compañías de
petróleo y gas más grandes del mundo una
compañía que recientemente anunció
planes para agregar 7.600 millones de
barriles de petróleo a su producción en
los próximos años lo que representa el
quinto aumento más grande en el mundo
podría socavar las negociaciones
y con este llamado terminamos nuestra
Crónica de medio ambiente pueden ver
este y todos los capítulos en France
24.com nosotros nos vemos pronto